so bishop e6
yeah so duda is having a thing is that
an alternative to bishop e6 because he
goes rookie six
whoa
i mean what about rook d8 rook d8 queen
c7 what's happening danny
uh well there's there's a mate on d1 i
think but there's queen c7 here that's
what i'm saying rookie rookie seven
queen dear screen v8 i beg your pardon
i'm going completely crazy
um
wow this is crazy still look after his
king and make sure that there's no
perpetual checks yeah so you just have
to cover the h line as long as black
doesn't allow any checks on that h line
it's an easy one and i also have to say
i think you can also swing the rook to
a3
[Music]
if you want to be super mean about it
should we show that it's deadly yeah um
so joe there's one threat as fran for
his ticks down to four seconds let's
keep an eye on him because he might
resign any second he's just brought his
queen down and white black can deliver a
forced checkmate by bringing his rook
across to this square he plays it and
because of these bishops this is going
to be checkmate van forest he's about to
resign rook takes pawn is unstoppable
and that will trap the white king in the
corner he does resign a beautiful finish
there from duda
wow young christophe duda he had such a
bad start to the tournament but
yesterday and today playing some
fantastic chess